i recently got a question from peter  what's the best way to organize  production test and dev environments for  my serverless app  well here's how i usually do it  let's start with production this is what  end users are accessing every day i  always set it up as a dedicated google  cloud project  most developers in my team do not have  admin access to it  next is test which i also put in  separate google cloud project so it  can't disturb production  finally we have the development  environment developers typically write  code on their local machines but they  need to also try it out in the cloud i  usually create one google cloud project  per developer each developer can use  their project to run unit tests or  experiments with project settings  to prevent these dev environments from  drifting too far from production we  delete and recreate them every few weeks  using scripts happy coding